- I mean, even doing, even
if people didn't know you,
like you look like a cool band dude.
- Thank you. Thank you.
- Like you just, you exude rock and roll.
- Happy birthday.
- Oh, thank you. Thank you.
I'm an official old man.
- Well, where were you
when I was growing up?
- I, in the United States, in
the Bronx. The Bronx, yeah.
- Until the planetarium,
he only thought the sky was one way.
- [Neil Degrasse Tyson] Yeah.
- So you have to be into
space, you wrote Rocket Man.
You have to like space.
- Oh, you took, you took my joke.
- Oh, (bleep)!
- I can't believe you did that to me.
- Oh my God. I didn't mean to.
- But it does have a, it
does have a line in it
that you, you'll make it, it says,
"All this science, I don't understand."
- [Kelly] Oh!
- Oh.
- [Bernie Taupin] There you go.
- Oh, you don't have to
understand as long as it works.
- [Bernie Taupin] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- You know where I got
the idea from, though?
- [Neil Degrasse Tyson]
Where, where was that?
- Ray Bradbury.
- Is that right?
- [Kelly] Oh.
- Yeah. He wrote a book
called The Illustrated Man.
- [Neil Degrasse Tyson] Yes.
- Which was one of his first
science fiction short stories.
And there was a story in
there called the Rocket Man.
- Oh my gosh.
- And that's where I lifted it from.
- I love it. You lifted it.
(laughter)
- But can I give my favorite
quote from Ray Bradbury?
Some people ask him,
Ray, why are you projecting
such apocalyptic futures,
For us in the world?
Is that where you think we're headed?
He said, "No, I write apocalyptic futures,
So, you know, to avoid them."
- Oh, I love that. Well, can't
avoid them all, asteroid.
But anyway, whatever.
Congrats, though, on the
Rock and Roll Hall of Fame.
That is so cool.
- Thank you very much. Thank you.
- [Kelly] I would've,
I would've thought that
that already would've happened, honestly.
- Yeah. That, that's
the general consensus.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But no, it's, it's, you know what?
- [Kelly] You slipped through
the cracks there for a minute.
- I slipped through the cracks. Yeah.
- Yeah. So, I hear you had a crazy night,
and I just love the company.
It was Freddie Mercury, I
think, and Billie Jean King?
- Yeah. It's kind of.
- [Kelly and Neil] What? How? What? What?
- [Kelly] What's happening
there? Yes. What's?
- Yeah, this story's in my book,
but um, yeah, this is back.
- Are you filtering yourself right now?
What should I say?
- Yeah. After your discussion
earlier in the show,
I thought, wait, I, I gotta
make I, I can do this.
- Get through the spot, the sensors.
- [Bernie Taupin] In the correct way.
Yeah. No, it was back
in the early seventies,
back when New York was a
little bit more dangerous
- [Kelly] Wild!
- than it is today.
It was really wild back then.
And I used to hang out
with Freddie a lot, and,
and Billie Jean King was a friend,
because Elton was a huge tennis fan.
- Hmm.
- And because he was Elton John, you know,
people sort of gravitate towards him.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- So, Billie Jean became a good friend.
She tried to teach me to play tennis once,
and I said, in my book, I said,
it's probably the only time
she's ever failed at anything.
(laughter)
- That's all right.
- But anyway, we just ended
up together one night,
and there was an establishment
that I used to go
to called Gilded Grape, which
was basically a drag bar,
but it had the, it, it
was well known for every,
every different possible kind
of person would go there.
You'd get sort of made guys
going there, wise guys,
just everybody, people off the street.
It was unbelievable.
And nobody paid any attention to the fact
that it was basically a drag club.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And all the people
that worked there used
to dress up as sort of famous movie stars
and theatrical divas and things like that.
But there was never any
trouble there at all.
I mean, everybody got along beautifully.
- Kind of Sounds like a great hang.
- Andy Warhol would go there
and all of the sort of the art community.
And it was great. It was just
a wonderful mix of people.
And the three of us ended
up going there one night,
and the tables were just
sort of formica tables
and stools, you know, really cheap.
Really cheap. And two of the waitresses,
the drag waitresses, got into a fight.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- With each other.
And they just happened to
land on top of our table
and completely demolished it.
It was like we'd be talking away.
And, and Freddie loved those
kind of places, so he was,
he was just egging them on, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yes dear. You go on, go on.
- [Kelly] Yes, dear.
- You get her. You get her dear.
But they literally landed on our table
and suddenly they jumped up
and they were friends again.
And we're, we're just sitting
with no tables on these chairs.
But like that, they came
and replaced it. as if
nothing had happened.
You know, they just put another table.
- You saw nothing.
- [Bernie Taupin] It didn't really happen.
- Or it's a usual thing, and you just get,
get the next table. Put it in.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- But, it was an
interesting threesome. Yes.
(Audience laughter)
- Oh my God, I love you.
Let's take a quick break. No segue there.
Bernie's new book is called
Scattershot Life Music:
Elton and Me. It's out now.
Stories just like that
are in there, so why not?
You have to jump in and buy that.